it's consisting of five probiotic
bacteria basically a consortium of
bacteria that is designed to address the
root cause of the bad breath as opposed
to the mins and gums and mouthwashes of
the world that just masks the bad breath
[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation we are following up on Indy
bio demo day we now have our alte in the
studio I'm really excited to talk to
kishore and patrick the co-founders
what's up guys remember to bring that
good how are you doing good thanks for
coming on to the show
thanks for having us i really appreciate
it yeah so okay this is really important
stuff i'm really excited because it's
actually probably one of the most
relatable applicable companies right
there in the daily use of people's lives
so or alta and we'll get a little bit
into your histories and what got you
here or alta a fresh breath probiotic so
give us give us a quick taste of the of
like fresh breath probiotics and then
we'll go to history and then we'll get
to the more nuanced later but give us
that fret that little taste yeah so the
actual taste off the table is a slight
minty flavor its consisting of five
probiotic bacteria basically a
consortium of bacteria that is designed
to address the root cause of the bad
breath as opposed to the mins and gums
and mouthwashes of the world that just
masks the bad breath okay so this what
you just said there I want to unpack
later getting to the roots instead of
masking we'll get to that later so
that's that's the quick bit on or Alton
now tell us about you guys so how do
human beings Indian German
how do you guys figure out I'm gonna go
into the u.s. I'm gonna pursue
entrepreneurship I'm gonna do biotech
stuff I'm gonna do breath stuff how did
that story unfold it's a long story from
my side because I started off as a
computer science engineer in India and I
did my masters and my bachelor's in
India and I flew into United States to
the University of Iowa go Hawks to do my
PhD in biomedical informatics in India I
had an thing where like after your after
your 10th grade you can either choose
only math physics or chemistry or
biology physics or chemistry and the
opportunities for math physics and
chemistry were much more than biology
physics and chemistry but I love math
and biology and I could not pursue it so
I had to take math physics and chemistry
and I had this void in me like I always
wanted to do biology and after I
finished my bachelor's in computer
science and masters in computer science
then I got this I read this book called
genome where they talked about how there
are new opportunities opening up in the
field of biology for computer scientists
where they need a lot of analyst
statisticians computer programmers to
understand the the genome projects that
are happening currently at various
research universities in the United
States so I applied to a bioinformatics
program but I could apply the skills as
a computer scientist and apply to
biology to understand various health and
disease concerns of citizens so that's
got that's what helped me to apply to
United States I did my PhD there and in
my PhD I mostly did cancer genetics and
cancer by informatics and some basic bio
informatics and then I got my first
graduated from University of Iowa got my
first job again in in Pioneer hybrid
which is a plant genetics company
and I was doing plant genetics s so I
made a switch from cancer genetics to
plant genetics or plant bioinformatics
and then I moved to Bayer CropScience
and that's where my introduction to
microbial by informatics happened and
that's what I ment Patrick - and and
Patrick is an excellent scientist so we
kinda and we both had these
entrepreneurial ambitions and we came up
with this idea but but Patrick will talk
a little bit about how we came up with
the actual idea but Patrick is my
colleague and a very good friend when we
were in bed crop science tell us about
the journey as well yeah so so my
background I was born Germany studied
their bachelor masa PhD and as many know
Germany has not the best weather in the
world so it's a pretty rainy especially
the University I was at so that's it's I
always say it's partially the reason I
wanted to go to a really nice warm place
after finishing my my PhD and so in DTI
I came to to California to do my postdoc
here in the Bay Area but also already in
Germany doing my studies actually was a
co-founder of a startup and as such you
know about San Francisco being the mecca
of startups so that was another big big
reason to actually move here what was
that startup they were doing so this was
in the browser game space at the time
you know if Facebook browser games was a
really big and it probably still is yeah
so that was it wasn't this realm yeah so
then here after my postdoc I joined
Bayer CropScience
where then eventually met Kishore and
basically of all my background my
studies were all focused on industrial
microorganisms so it's can be tell us
about that yeah we're both doing that
industrial microorganisms right well we
we were we are basically doing soil
microbiome studies so we were trying
like the way we came up with this idea
we were working in plant microbiomes
where we were identifying bacteria that
make the plants grow better or help them
fight fungal diseases so we realized
that you know patrick has a patent on
that and i have some coming up but we
realized ok if this works for the plants
it should work for humans as well and
you know a we realize that we could
rebalance the oral bacteria from a
disease to a healthy state by
introducing healthy bacteria yeah so we
were doing the same thing for the plans
we thought that's translatable to humans
I mean they're already working on God
but nobody's focusing on the world
health yes health is a serious concern
and it's part of the GI tract yeah yeah
yes the opening right yes the opening
exactly it's interesting yeah but um I
just wanted to say along the way so it
started with what adding healthy
bacteria to plant eco soil ecosystems
and now it's like what how can that be
applied to humans yeah so and maybe
tumors before that the rhizosphere which
is really the the microbiome of the
plant the what the rhizosphere rises
rises my fear yeah is the soil soil
that's like the microbiome of the plant
exactly you mean the first time I've
ever heard that analogy that spectrum so
the rhizosphere is a much more complex
environment than the mouse actually so
there are thousands over thousands of
microbes known to exist around the
rhizosphere the human microbiome has an
average only like 700 different species
at each individual like overall there
are also a few thousands even the mouth
in the mouth yeah yeah and and so we
really thought basically we tackled a
more difficult problem in the past when
we were working at the rhizosphere so
now translating all this knowledge and
yes you know the algorithms we have
developed in the past to the oral
microbiome would make a lot of sense and
actually allow us to be even more
impactful with that because it is a
a simpler but still very complex field
so then what was the moment for you to
when you were there doing all this the
rise rise of sphere of the microbiome of
plants and you were learning about this
making your own algorithms figuring this
out and then how did you guys go let's
let's do it let's do this you know how
that happened okay
all right so um so myself I am sometimes
plaque was with cavities
whereas Kishore has like perfect oral
health so you know he wouldn't even have
to brush he does it but he wouldn't have
to you know he wouldn't get cavities and
so the reason is that his oral
microbiome is just a very balanced and
healthy one whereas mine seems to be
suboptimal what does a healthy versus an
imbalanced world microbiome look like
yeah is that what do you call it an oil
biome oral microbiome or microbiome okay
so um it is not like one specific target
state where you have a certain number of
microbes
it's basically an infinite number of of
states that yes could exist but there
are what what the disease states usually
have in common is that they are an
overabundance of certain detrimental
bacteria whereas we know which ones that
is there are certain strains known
there's streptococcus mutans for example
which is associated with tooth decay but
there are various others and this field
is not exhaustively known actually so
it's there still research going on as we
speak as we take samples of our poop may
we also take samples of our world
microbiome to figure that out as at the
same time it seems like a good idea
exactly and it's obviously much more
accessible and easier for people to
donate their samples to to others cause
I will ask you that later I will ask you
if you are interested in taking oral as
well okay so then the moment though when
you were like aha
let's
you you were talking about the oral
health differences between you two
yeah right so so um I think it was one
day I came actually back from a dentist
visit and was just a little frustrated
about hearing that there might be
another cavity here and there although
you know I'm lost and brush and and do
everything you possibly can do and you
know we were just sitting over a beer
and thought well you know we do this as
a day job to figure out what are the
healthy microbes for plants and we put
them on the seeds and they grow strong
and vigorous and protected so why are we
not doing this for the oral microbiome
too in essence it was really like
self-interest at first how can I improve
my own situation that may be of my
family and friends and then very soon
this idea grew grew much bigger because
you know that most people don't know it
but there are 95% of Americans who
suffer from some sort of oral condition
which is a staggering number and and
what would out of the 95 percent that
suffer some oral condition what are the
top oral conditions that people usually
suffer from you know so the top oral
conditions are tooth decay and gum
disease and bad breath okay now okay I
think people are familiar with bad
breath maybe not so much the causes but
then the gum disease people kind of can
see the gum lining receding over time
and then gum line receding I don't think
I've got to do with I mean we are not
sure but you have gum disease and that
also has some implications in bad breath
but I would say the like the overarching
that there's three conditions bad breath
tooth decay and gum disease
and then again within gum disease there
is gingivitis periodontitis and there's
like a bunch of things Wow and and for
each thing there is a different
microbiome that causes these conditions
right like for example Patrick was
alluding to the restrictor caucus
mutants that causes
Cary's or tooth decay but everybody has
streptococcus mutans but there are
certain conditions and certain presence
of other bacteria that makes it
pathogenic or that have I mean that
causes all conscience sorts of it makes
it pathogenic and causes other disease
conditions around in the mouth so we
have to identify what kind of consortium
at Korea are causing health and disease
and okay so yeah that's that's that's a
key there okay what consortium bacteria
caused the the tooth decay and gum
disease bad breath and then and then
what are the the ones that cause good
health good health and so then what have
been your tools of analysis for that so
Patrick can talk about the tools so so
besides I want to start beside myself
there we have another team of
co-founders so they're four of us in
total David Drake and jefra baños they
are both long-term professors at the
University of Iowa College of Dentistry
both individually have over 30 years of
experience in analyzing the oral
microbiology of humans so with with
their help we were able to BC dig really
deep into the literature and I
understand which micro what is known and
which of the known microbes would act
well together this is when we started
experimenting and then eventually came
up with a proprietary solution of five
strains that really work with
synergistically very effectively to
fight bad breath and the five
proprietary strains that you came up
with to fight bad breath that these
fight bad breath and gum disease and
tooth decay or just just a bad breath so
this all first peroxide which we were
talking about later I guess is targeted
for bad breath so this is specifically
designed for bad breath what does the
tongue look like at a microscopic level
it's like little bristles right with
little things the next to each other
like this it so it is a it is a surface
riddled with carom crevasses and it's a
very rough surface this is also why for
example if you take mouthwashes you will
never be able to or even turn scrapers
you will never be able to remove all
bacteria from your channel they are
always hiding down down in the offices
and they will grow back from there
especially with mouthwashes it can be a
problem because the tremendous strains
tend to grow back faster than have you
know beneficial ones and then you were
usually often left off worse than you
were before it's like there is a
constant state of war in the mouth so
that is different think of all these
bacterias different tribes and they're
just fighting for competition in the
mouth like they have their own weapons
they have their own antibiotics to
suppress the other ones so sometimes
they work together they make alliances
with other species of bacteria work
together for the health of the mouth but
also there'll be other alliances where
they work together for the disease each
state of the mouth so they become
pathogenic so they recruit other species
both for disease and health so it's you
can think of the mouth as like a war
zone yeah we're like this there is this
good and bad guys constantly at war and
they make alliances and they have
different set of weaponry some has a
better and buy like some more like
voracious at you know eating up all the
resources this sounds like the evolution
of humanity exactly and and that that's
constantly happening in your mouth and
in the guard in the skin everywhere even
in the house to like you know like for
example if you windows and there's the
reason why I think you know our elders
say open your windows is to let the new
bacteria come in so that there's not one
kind of few types of bacteria that is
overtaking them so you're maintaining a
healthy balance of the bacteria and in
everywhere like in the mouth that's why
you brought a fresh oxygen through
exactly yeah yeah but the air comes
bacteria yeah okay
you were you were just going somewhere
that's why you were saying bread that's
why you brush it
because you open up new space for new
bacteria yeah when you're brushing the
teeth you are removing the you know
whatever is on the upper surface of the
T there the tongue and making space for
others exactly so you're not letting one
particular type or a few particular
types just outgrow and and how good are
the others and become pathogenic so
that's like the physical effect I mean
like physically you are removing them so
if we use our probiotic what happens is
they are you know they're probiotics
their natural environment is the mouth
so they actually proliferate faster and
make sure that the other ones are not
coming in and occupying it the oral
space how did you pick the five or six
strains eight like patrick said
literature the literature we also have
two professors co-founders yes who are
who have over 30 years of experience in
the space so they helped us with this
formulation and the formulation now does
the do you a deal list the you don't
list them here because that's the IP
right so they are listed they are just
unlisted in the exact ratios we designed
them to be from the solitary probiotic
blend right thank you
streptococcus streptococcus Salif
various that's great
m18 streptococcus all various k12 lacto
lacto caucus lactis will lacto bacillus
rotary and lactobacillus salah verse and
you see that three of those have
salivary s in it so the natural
environment is the saliva so they found
the first found them in the saliva so so
there so for example I'm an Indian I
tried better in India right so the
natural environment is the is the saliva
so they grow better than the others the
pathogenic ones and and they are better
at using up the resources in the mouth
the private
the the other pathogenic bacteria from
getting any resources our foothold in
the mouth interesting and then the this
is a hundred and three milligrams of the
probiotic blend and then what percentage
of the entire probiotic supplement is
that hundred and three milligrams do we
know how much is each one so why are you
asking about the weight of a single
weight yeah like what percentage of the
actual tablet is just the probiotic
blend and then what percentage of it is
xylitol microcrystalline cellulose
actually are the top of my head I don't
know we had that data of course but of
course yeah I don't know the season this
is this is my job is to is to ask these
questions and now you're like I'm gonna
know that so interesting
now can you so the ones that don't say
salivary salivary Asst lactis greater ii
right what are what are those so the the
naming oftentimes suggest their origin
not not always so these all these
strains are what's in the industry
called grass so that means generally
generally recognized as safe so they all
originate from you know healthy human
subjects not all of them have been named
sella various because similar strains
have been found in other environments
before and then you name them after the
next closest species or strain and
that's why the names are not necessarily
all ending instead of areas and then how
do you know that having how many times
have you now tested these five versus
adding a sixth one versus taking one out
yeah so there were several iterations
through which we've we've went so not
all not all probiotics and you know
synergize very well together you know
some might even antagonize themselves so
we found that this this combination is
the most efficacious
let in me and that might also be true
for different populations of people as
in my oral microbiome the difference
someone across the world right so or
alta might have to come in different for
different cultures different of people
very possible yeah so you talking bigger
you're sketching now on a surf topic
that's really interesting so the
microbiome of every individual is
basically like I finger vibes percent
different right it's like a finger
parfaits it's really unique to you but
it just the the difference with the
fingerprint is that it's really it's
staying for the life of you for your
lifetime the the microbiome is actually
constantly also evolving and changing so
if you eat one day if you drink hot tea
you sample before and after drinking hot
tea you will probably get different
results even worse if you take an
antibiotic because of some other
condition after you're taking the
antibiotic you rapidly change the
microbiome in your mouth and your gut so
wherever it comes in contact with and
other things are in impacting your
microbiome like obviously your eating
habits your oral hygiene routines yes
even if you have things like you open it
you sleep with an open mouth if it
changes like various things if you do a
lot of sport exercises how much water
you drink if you're smoking alcoholic
all these things rapidly impact in
microbiome yeah that's like it does in
variables right there that are right
which you know which kind of then the
next question would be oh so how do you
know this works for most people yes and
and the answers this was designed
specifically to target the strains that
are known to cause bad breath so if you
have bad breath most likely you contain
strains you have strains that these
strains that we provide
target or fight so regardless of a kind
of condition you have yeah and there's a
high probability that this consortium of
bacteria is going to be efficacious
against your condition how does one
measure if
they have bad breath because when
everyone wakes up in the morning don't
we all have bad breath yeah so that
there are various reasons for bad breath
and we also want to distinguish clearly
bad breath from you know eating food
that causes bad breath because of the
food being sold so we're not we're not
addressing that this is like a temporary
condition garlic if you eat garlic you
smell like a so we're not going to do
anything about that but we're really
focusing us account of the chronic
halitosis so yeah people have constantly
and also when they wake up in the
morning so one other thing to touch up
on what you said is regards to like how
the dynamic the microbiome is but for
each disease condition we also believe
there is a core microbiome in a sense
like there is certain certain set of
consurtio bacteria that definitely occur
in a certain disease condition so if we
address and target those bacteria we
will be with that with our own
consortium and we will be able to do
that right but for the rest you know
that's the core microbiome and there's
the core second Saoirse bacteria that
cause that particular condition so if we
can target them we will be able to
mitigate that condition but there will
be a lot of other species of bacteria
floating around in the mouth I got
nothing to do with the condition so back
to the war analogy are you sending
soldiers in to combat the bad is that
kind of the yeah we're sending the
soldiers in but also that's their that's
their home so we're sending the soldiers
in to their own country to their own
country and and and then what they're
doing is they're kind of taking out the
bad actors in the country okay and once
I know it's the gum disease tooth decay
bad breath and then proliferating
bleeding out bleeding the others out
breeding and out convenient for
resources so then so then the this has
to be taken twice a day it's chewable
tablet daily and then take it twice a
day morning evening
avoid food and drink for 30 minutes so
let it dissolve in your mouth
so over the period of time and then is
this a when is this available for the
market and what kind of testing do you
have to go through FDA right yeah food
and drug so so your first question is
when is it when is it available right so
it's going to be available to answer
them in Reverse so the testing first
yeah yeah okay testing battery balance
yeah okay so you're asking whether you
have to be tested in order to take those
yeah so the reason you don't have to do
this is a dietary supplement so it is
not a drug and and as such you know it
is yeah it is supplementing your regular
diet and is healthy I make cookies and I
want to sell them at Whole Foods I'd
literally just have to bring my cookies
to the buyer at Whole Foods so yeah so
then similarly yeah okay dietary
supplement so it is a is a acknowledged
class of the FDA it is not a drug though
so yeah there's really a class of
products called dietary supplements but
then the FDA does have certain like
measurements on like the meat at the
grocery store right they have these
certain foods get make sure that they're
safe at the grocery store
yeah that kind of goes back to what I
mentioned earlier so that the data
remains that the but if you have
probiotics in there they need to be
generally recognized as safe so grass
approved if you will and so obviously
our strains adhere to that and there are
some other there are some other
regulations when it comes to you know
the supplement label certain things that
are written on the on the bottle needs
to need to be compliant and then the we
do want to see this
then on the on the checkouts right next
to like the tic tacs and all that other
kind of bug gums and the gum and all
that other kind of stuff so like what's
the distribution when is it available
yeah all that good stuff too yeah so it
will be available in December we are
directly launching through our website
Oh
people will be able to buy at wwlp.com
from December onwards gotta love that a
6 character domain name yeah that's so
good yeah exactly enough to get in get
the dot-com domain as well yeah and then
we'll have to keep some or alta on our
on our shelf of product with all the
other ones and so we'll pass it all off
to the different people that walk in
through the door yes Ember that's quick
yeah yeah he's coming down in December
and and and also to actually reiterate
what patrick said it so it again comes
back to the walk type of scenario so
there's like few concerts of bad actors
that are common across all the people
that have bad breath and we have a
concern of bacteria that will fight
these consurtio bacteria that cause bad
breath so so it you know it will it is
efficacious for the majority of people
so it will work for most people
yeah well I mean it does it takes some
time to dissolve in your mouth yeah
that's fine okay how long does it
usually take to dissolve like 5-10
minutes that's fine when I when I try
you know I used to do it like every day
and it took it took me three minutes
maybe I have too much saliva in my mouth
you have lots of lots of saliva in your
mouth
let's show as well as we can what seeing
again here's our alta and then here's
what the cool
nice pop it in
it's a cherry limeade favor that you
have I guess cherry limeade great but
our our first Cheryl I mean xylitol
right yep
it has it has a little is a sugar but
our first batch has only mint flavor in
it we don't okay so there's no cherry
lemon or orange or anything we tried
these three things but our first product
that's launching mm-hmm this December is
just I mean flavors so but you are what
you are trying right now is cherry
limeade which 2019 at some point will be
on the website yeah I like the model of
distribution through website is there
also interest in the 711s and the
Costco's and whatnot of the world yeah
so so subsea like first will be selling
through our website and trying to build
a strong brand you know strong dtc brand
and after that we want to go to amazon
and subsequently go to all these retail
pharmaceutical changes we have quite a
bit of interest right now we will
probably go that route but not in the
next few months yeah
so we have a lot of retail
pharmaceutical chains that have
approached us to actually to see if we
would be interested in placing on their
shelves
we haven't I mean you know we're talking
to them but it won't happen in the next
few months what do we expect the a 60
capsule bottle to retail for on your
website so it cost $39.97
40 bucks 30 bucks so like 65 cents a
tablet or something chewable tablet
something like that cool around that
okay but yeah that's like 2 bucks a day
or a buck a 50 a day or whatever yeah
yeah but the thing is a lot of people
who don't have bad breath don't realize
it but bad breath is a serious issue it
affects people's social personal and
professional lives you know like you
only know it if you experience it you
know
it causes severe self-esteem and
self-confidence issues yes it has a
strong psychological effect too mm-hmm I
think what I looted too early is also
pointed that is important to understand
that this is not a mint or a mouthwash
or something that temporarily masks your
bad breath yep
so this is really going to the source of
the problem and trying to naturally
shift your oral microbiome towards a
healthy state so that also means if you
know for a day don't take it you don't
see a difference and you still have good
breath because the microbes live in your
mouth they actively cover all surfaces
and prevent the bad bacteria to adhere
and busy start growing again and this
effect you know depends on the person
might last several days two weeks so it
is it's a very different concept than
just buying a box of toys or something
yes yes no one else is going at the
source of the bad breath with a chewable
tablet is that right no one else is
doing that yeah that's exactly right I
thought this was great I just tried it I
thought it was fantastic
yeah thank you yeah it's a good
formulation your job so I think we
covered a pretty good amount of what we
needed to talk about something I guess
that I thought was was interesting to
mention to you guys to ask you guys
about is the like the further future for
our alte what does the this you know the
further further future look like how
many is this you know what are the other
or all two products that you expect to
make yeah what's your roadmap look like
for a little more so our you know our
first product for bad breath which isn't
right in your hands is is launching
direct-to-consumer in december and we
are working on another
probiotic for gum disease which we'll be
launching in q1 of 2019 and the third
one for tooth decay which we're
launching in q2 of 2019
but what we're also has different
chewable tablets they're having
different compositions of the healthy
exaggerations that is correct but but
what we are also trying to do is we're
also trying to build an oral de AI
platform so some select customers who
buy through our website will get an
option of sending their saliva samples
what we do in a mailer so if they send
us the saliva samples back we do any
sequencing of their saliva samples and
send them their reports so the advantage
of for them was exactly so advantage for
them to sending us a saliva samples is a
custom formula no no there's not custom
formula yet right so they'd be down the
wine maybe so we're doing free oral
microbiome analysis for them completely
free yeah exactly
Oh yep so and we'll do a free oral
microbiome analysis for them but there's
some select customers that don't bite
through our website oh okay so once your
customer for a bit you can get a free
survival microbiome yeah so there's an
option like let's say you are a customer
right you're buying through our website
and and we'll do an option to send their
saliva samples and know more about the
role of microbiome so so you are as you
do a lot of science podcast you might be
interested in knowing how your oral
microbiome is so they have the gut
sequence exactly so so we will send you
a salawa sampling kit and you can send
your saliva samples to us we sequence
your saliva samples and then what we do
is we send you back the reports so you
have this and this particular species of
bacteria and over emergence and and the
other species in less abundance and and
what we what we'll do eventually is you
know
we build a database of this samples and
also the sequencing of the microbial
profits of the samples and what we want
to do is eventually use this database to
design new therapeutics and refine
existing probiotics this will serve as
the core of our future products so right
now we have these three things coming
out from the experience of the two other
co-founders Jeff and David but all the
future products will be designed by this
AI platform that we are building so and
what and yeah go ahead just a few things
to add on we also want to want to learn
a little bit more about the people who
would send us survival samples because
what's really important is not only
their microbiome and in terms of DNA
sequencing results but also what are
their habits looking like you know what
is their oral hygiene habit what their
eating habits you know do they have
maybe certain you know conditions that
in the long run we can correlate with a
imbalance of oral microbiome bacteria so
that we can relieve correlate health
status and habits with microbiome data
which then really allows us to fine-tune
and even develop more targeted
probiotics to help as you for example
earlier said different ethnicities or
you know various other sub sectors and
so that they will have much more
efficacious probiotics then maybe
possibly which is currently possible and
there is also a recent body of evidence
that suggests the link between oral
microbiome and systemic diseases like
Alzheimer's you can and also preterm
births cardiovascular disease so this
database will help us you know connect
all the starts so how the oral
microbiome plays a role in system and
diseases as well yeah
hmm now give me one more time with all
of the oral microbiome that you will
have all that information then you can
target to help people of different
ethnicities of different compositions of
different met bad bad oral microbiomes
are even geographies because like for
example in India there will be probably
more vegetarians versus here right so
they might need a little bit different
probiotic verses enable in United States
okay is there is there something else
wait I also realized I can't drink water
for 30 minutes now so what's the reason
you need it to sit set into you don't
want it to wash down you want yeah right
um so ideally what we recommend as
people after their regular oral hygiene
routine in the morning and evening take
the tablet let it dissolve and then try
to go sleep right away let basically the
good bacteria rehydrate as they are in a
dormant state right now let them busy
rehydrate start the metabolism and one
of the first things they will do Express
certain proteins that allow them to
adhere to the surface of the mouth and
thereby starting to compete right away
with the existing bad bacteria and and
subsequently they will go through other
modes of action to you know start
fighting the bad bacteria and that just
takes some time so if you would for
example just swallow this tablet yeah
you would not get any help anyhow this
is this is very different from normal
most of the time people associate
probiotics with gut health you kind of
want a sue [ __ ] around your mouth even
like move it around from the back
corners and yeah
suggest and the thing is one thing we
observed consistently is the most ideal
time would be to take it right before
going to bed and that gives them six to
eight hours to grow and colonize the
mouth and the thing is and during that
time when you wake up in the morning
there is no longer any biofilm on the
teeth and the tongue because these guys
who are natural to the mouth are
proliferating and growing in the mouth
so you wake up in the morning feeling
clean actually that's a really
interesting test two is two one I go to
bed take on wake up in the morning and
just go yeah yes so what you just did is
actually a most people do this to try to
test their own breath yeah and it's
actually been proven to be very
inefficient
so it you just like you can't really
smell your own growth as well so you
know it's kind of used to the you know
this is not coming out so yeah so what
you really want to do if you really want
to know about your breath on you alone
because the best test is released you
have a significant other or friends
smell yeah they need to remember from
the previous day what it smelled like
right we're bottle it up you can do it
yourself a few so the best thing is you
actually lick oh it's a lick like yeah
I'm off your hand here wait maybe 20
seconds and then and then smell yeah
mine doesn't smell that good you could
come down to our lab and we'll do the
test for you so we have something called
a Halle meter which measures the
volatile sulfur compounds in your breath
and we can tell you how about the
threshold or how bad your breath is or
how good your breath is how a mirror
halli meter how a meter which the
halitosis halitosis is the is the
medical world in front of all you guys
at two days ago
the indie bio roast because I was just
you guys say words like this so yeah
halitosis you know you just see the
biotech people are so funny
I actually prefer a bad breath tooth
decay and gum disease because it's
better to communicate that way and and
people really understand a situation is
a gingivitis or they don't know what you
know a lot of people don't understand
what it is but how it ptosis is what
again the it's the bad breath so it's
the it's the medical term for by the
medical term for it how interesting
halitosis yeah cuz sometimes it also
makes you feel like though I know what
those is and then you get the
superiority ego thing and you if you say
bad breath you get you know 95% people
know what that is Howie ptosis 1% of it
I think in Spanish is called a lamento
which is halitosis ala me anta and I
think sound interesting do you guys did
we cover how is there something else
that you thought was important to cover
on the show the direct-to-consumer
launch is happening in this December
please go to WWE and fire exactly and
you click on shop and we will get you
will send you the product and just take
one pill in the morning one pill in the
evening and you'll be able to see the
difference in just two weeks
go ahead and buy and try our product
maybe we can do like a couple dollar
code maybe like a 10% off code something
like that yeah so we will send it to you
maybe you can add that to your youth
person option will maybe do the code
simulation fantage the name and then
we'll add that to the bio as well cool
simulation viewers will get a 10%
discount awesome that's cool you might
want to mention that that you can
actually already buy the product as a
pre purchase oh yeah website right now
also and we have already a few hundred
people actually on pre-order perf so if
you want to join that group that's good
stuff that would be great so yeah we'll
throw the code in it's already ready for
pre-order first batch will hopefully get
to people before Christmas that's the
plan
definitely before Christmas awesome
what a fun time this has been yeah do
you have another yeah well you bi eating
all the nice food during Christmas or
save yourself someone get you some fresh
bread using our or alte fresh bread
probiotic oh this has been so
enlightening thank you very much for
building what you're building and for
teaching us about it there's been a lot
of fun it is if your if your significant
other has bad breath ask him to buy this
product or alter calm or buy for him
[Laughter]
yeah same thing same thing for a
gentleman if your lady has a son or
daughter if your parent has bad breath
yeah this has been a lot of fun Thank
You Patrick what a pleasure thanks
everybody thanks for tuning in we would
greatly appreciate it go check out our
alte also if you guys had a good time
give us a comment below they'll let us
know your thoughts about what you think
about the product service go and build
the future go and manifest your dreams
and in the world thanks everyone for
tuning in peace out
[Music]